Salut. Aujourd'hui, on va parler de quelque chose d'un petit peu passionnant
qui sont les rappels automatiques qu'on peut se mettre dans le cerveau.
Un petit peu comme l'application "rappel" sur les téléphones portables.
J'avais jamais vraiment pensé à vous parler de ça
et à l'issu d'un spectacle à Lyon au mois de mars dernier
ça remonte un petit peu.
Il y a Guillaume qui m'en a parlé, qui m'a envoyé un mail à ce propos.
L'idée est la suivante. C'est que quand on fait quelque chose, quand on se retrouve à un endroit.
Il faudrait que, dans notre cerveau, il y ait un processus qui fasse "Ting ! Rappelle-toi de ça."
C'est parti. Générique !
Pour bien commencer cette vidéo, je vais répondre à deux questions que vous me posez beaucoup.
La première, c'est que le prochain Live aura lieu ce dimanche 28 à 18h.
Je l'ai beaucoup bossé donc il devrait changer des deux lives précédents.
J'ai un peu le trac.
Et la deuxième, c'est toutes les questions que vous me posez à propos du livre.
Toutes les réponses, vous pouvez les trouver dans la vidéo que j'ai faite à ce sujet et qui est dans la description.
Concernant cette fameuse mémoire, il y a un truc qu'on appelle la madeleine de Proust
qui est que quand on sent une odeur, quand on entend un son
on a une masse de souvenirs accrochés à ça qui peuvent remonter.
Même des choses qu'on pensait avoir oubliées depuis longtemps.
C'est bon signe. ça veut dire qu'on peut faire une connexion entre quelque chose d'environnemental
et un souvenir.
Donc, potentiellement, on pourrait créer artificiellement une action mémorielle liée à un environnement.
Par exemple, j'arrive devant chez moi : "il faut que je pense à faire ça".
Dans les faits, c'est pas aussi simple.
Il y a une technique que ceux qui ont mon âge et au de-là connaissent
C'est la technique du nœud au mouchoir.
Alors, pourquoi ? Je vous le donne en mille, Émile.
Parce qu'il s'agit de faire un nœud à son mouchoir.
Propre, de préférence.
C'est une technique de mnémotechnique pour se rappeler de faire quelque chose
qui a été très populaire au début du XIXème siècle
On retrouve même des références à ça dans des bouquins, des romans, des livres.
Pour se rappeler de devoir faire quelque chose, on faisait un nœud à son mouchoir
on le mettait dans sa poche.
Ce qui fait que quand on sortait le mouchoir, on voyait le nœud
et on ne savait plus ce qui était prévu mais on savait qu'on avait oublié de faire quelque chose.
Non, en temps normal le souvenir remontait.
Il y a quand même quelque chose d'intéressant à ça.
C'est la rupture de l'habitude mais ça, on va y venir.
Parce que oui, il y a un plan, une séquence.
Les vidéos sont écrites. On dirait pas, hein ?
J'ai même ma petite bouteille d'eau pour essayer de bien parler.
Dans l'idée, le secret est quand même de créer un ancrage psychologique.
C'est quelque chose qu'on a vu sur la chaine par rapport aux émotions.
Pour ressentir une émotion particulière, il faut se remettre dans un état particulier.
Mais, on pourrait essayer de l'appliquer à de la mémoire.
Le problème est que l'ancrage psychologique tel  qu'on l'entend
c'est quelque chose qui se travaille dans le temps
alors que là, si c'est pas quelque chose de récurent,
forcément, ça fonctionne moins bien.
Mais si c'est quelque chose de récurent,
alors, on peut faire cet exercice-là.
C'est-à-dire, fermer les yeux, se poser dans une émotion un peu calme, neutre.
Il faut se visualiser en train de faire cette chose-là.
Si par exemple, à chaque fois, j'oublie de fermer la porte de mon garage,
l'idée de revivre cette scène mentalement, souvent, dans un état de relaxation,
de me voir mettre la main sur la poignée de la porte,
et en faisant ça, d'imaginer une grande clé lumineuse imaginaire.
Plus je vais faire ça, plus je vais ancrer cette association d'idées.
plus dans la vraie vie, alors quand je vais toucher la poignée de la porte,
cette clé me reviendra et je vais me rappeler de fermer la porte.
ça, c'est bien pour les trucs récurrents.
Mais pour les trucs ponctuels,
Le premier problème vient du fait d'être dans l'instant présent.
ça aussi on va y revenir avant la fin de la vidéo.
Mais il faut vraiment être dans l'instant présent pour pouvoir apprécier en fait
les stimulations autour de nous, environnementales, et faire revenir quelque chose de lié.
Parce que si on est concentré sur autre chose dans sa tête, qu'on se fait un peu bouffer par son mental et par ses idées,
alors on est pas assez attentif à ce qu'il se passe autour de nous.
Si vous voulez d'ailleurs un de ces quatre, je vous ferai une vidéo sur l'instant présent, dites le moi dans les commentaires si ça vous tente.
Donc je crois que les meilleures méthodes pour les choses ponctuelles, ça reste de faire une rupture d'habitudes
comme je vous ai dit précédemment.
C'est-à-dire quelque chose qui ne devrait pas être là,  où qui ne devrait pas être comme ça,
et le fait de le constater, ça va nous ramener au pourquoi on a fait ça au départ.
Malin l'Fabien !
Un truc tout bête pour reprendre l'exemple de Guillaume qui se posait la question pour sa boîte à gants.
Et bien Guillaume, quand tu vas dans ta voiture, je pense qu'habituellement du garde ton manteau sur toi ou tu le mets sur le siège passager.
Je ne vais pas te le dire de le mettre dans la boîte à gants, ça va être un petit peu galère,
par contre tu peux le mettre dans ton coffre.
Tu vas perdre quelques secondes à faire ça, mais au moment où tu vas descendre de la voiture,
tu vas forcément chercher ton manteau, il va être dans le coffre, tu vas te rappeler que tu l'as mis dans le coffre,
donc tu vas te rappeler que tu l'as mis dans le coffre pour penser à prendre quelque chose dans la boîte à gants.
Je pense que le système est clair ?!
Ou pas... donc je vais prendre un deuxième exemple.
C'est toujours basé sur le génialisime noeud dans le mouchoir en fait.
Si vous devez absolument faire quelque chose dans votre journée et que vous avez peur d'oublier,
et que vous avez une montre, dont vous vous servez,
vous pouvez arrêter la trotteuse de la montre et laisser ça sur midi tout pile.
Comme ça à chaque fois que vous allez regarder l'heure, vous allez voir que la motnre est bloquée, vous allez vous rappelez de pourquoi elle s'est bloquée,
et vous allez penser à faire cette action.
Un autre exemple avec le téléphone portable, je change mon code, mon code de déverouillage, je mets la date du jour.
Parce que sinon à force je vais aussi oublier les codes temporaires que je mets.
Ce qui fait qu'à chaque fois que je me prends un vent en voulant déverouiller mon téléphone,
je me rappelle que j'ai changé temporairement, et je me rappelle de pourquoi j'ai fait ça.
Et enfin pour terminer, j'aimerai prendre la situation à l'inverse.
C'est-à-dire quand on ne se souvient plus de si on a fait quelque chose ou pas.
Je pernais l'exemple de la porte de garage, je suppose que ça vous ai déjà arrivé de vous dire: "Est-ce que j'ai pensé à faire ça en partant ?"
ou "Est-ce que j'ai fait ça aujourd'hui ?"
C'est très très agaçant parce que des fois ça nous oblige à revenir en arrière pour constater qu'on avait tout bien fait.
J'ai une astuce pour ça, si vous voulez vous en souvenir, il suffit d'au moment où vous faites l'action, d'y prêter une réelle attention.
Pour ma part, vraiment c'est un truc, je ne sais jamais si j'ai fermé à clé ou pas, donc maintenant que je ferme une porte à clé en partant,
je me regarde le faire réellement et je dis à voix haute en chuchotant...
Parce que sinon les voisins vont commencer à me prendre pour un ouf...
Je dis: "Je suis en train de fermer la porte".
Et rien que le fait de faire ça, je prête cette attention à l'action pour que ça devienne un vrai souvenir dans la mémoire épisodique,
et que je m'en souvienne si je me pose la question dans la journée.
Très utile ! Je vous recommande de faire ça !
Quand vous fermerez la porte de chez vous, rappelez-vous que vous l'avez fermée.
Voilà...
Et en parlant de mémoire et d'oubli, comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de liker et de vous abonner.
Et rendez-vous samedi matin à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]